Hi, everybody. I'm Rachael,
and I lead our
customer marketing here at Posit.
It was so nice to see so
many of you last week at the
conference and Thank you to
everybody who joined us both in
person and virtually.
A lot of our time was focused
on last week's conference,
as you could imagine,
So rather than skipping
the session this month,
we're just gonna do things
a little bit different.
At last week's conference,
Joe Roberts gave a talk on
package security that I thought
would be helpful as part
of our workflow demos here.
I recorded this part because
I'm actually on vacation this week,
but Ryan and Joe will be hanging out
with you all in the chat right here.
So if you have any questions
today or maybe follow-up
questions from last week, you
can ask them in the YouTube
chat and we also have a
slider link where you can ask them
anonymously too.
And I've shown that slido
link here on the screen.
But thank you again for joining us,
and I'll turn it over to Joe.
Hi. I'm Joe Roberts, and I'm
a product manager here at Posit.
And one of the most common
questions I get asked
especially by IT administrators and
security teams is how to
make sure the public packages
that their data scientists want
to use are safe.
So today, we're going
to explore that topic.
And we're gonna start with
an overview of the main public
repositories used by data scientists
working in R and Python
to understand how they
work, and more importantly,
how they differ in
their approaches to package publishing.
We'll also explore some of
the more common types of security
risks in using public packages.
And we'll look at strategies
to mitigate those risks using
tools like Posit
Package Manager.
So let's get started. And,
let's take a look at the main
public package repositories
for data science.
CRAN is the primary
repository for R packages.
Bioconductor is also
widely used for R packages,
primarily in data
science, life sciences.
And on the Python side, the
Python package index or PI PI.
Cran and biogonductor take
a similar approach to packages,
And if you've ever submitted
a package to be published on
CRAN, you know exactly
how stringent those requirements are.
Each package has to pass a
comprehensive set of checks to
ensure the package is properly
formed and documented,
builds properly, doesn't cause
any other packages to fail.
Most importantly, from
a security standpoint,
these packages must be
submitted in entirely source
code so there's full
transparency of what is
contained within the package,
and it will it will go
through it a actual human
verification before
being published.
It's like the exclusive club
with the bouncer out front
where they may not make
sure you can dance,
but they definitely are gonna
make sure you're well dressed
before letting you in.
In contrast, PyPI takes the
opposite approach. PyPI is much
more like Wikipedia,
a completely open repository
where anyone can create an
account and publish packages.
Both in source or
binary packages,
which then become instantly
available to everyone around
the world. This isn't
necessarily a bad thing as it
does make a far wider array
of packages available,
though it does pose some
additional security risk we'll
have to take a closer look at.
So let's start with
the security risks now.
And the first security risk
is around the more fundamental
question of package quality,
or does this package accurately
do what it claims to do?
And that's not always an
easy question to answer,
especially if you're
not a domain expert,
but there are some other
more objective factors you can look
at to help you assess quality.
Things like the number of
package downloads or how many
other people are
using this package.
The author's reputation is this
package author well known in
the community? Do they have
a lot of other well used
packages, that
they've published?
Is this package
well documented.
Are there the
functions documented?
Are there instructional
guides, vignettes,
or other tutorials available?
And how frequently is
the package updated?
When was the last update?
Is this is it actively
maintained and frequently
updated with fixes?
And finally, I mean,
does the package include a
comprehensive set of tests to
verify that the functionality
is working correctly?
So how do we mitigate package
quality concerns? Well,
the obvious option is for
someone to carefully scrutinize
the package and make
a determination.
But as we pointed out earlier,
that's not always easy.
Fortunately,
the community has developed some
tools to help with those
assessments. For example,
our friends over at the R
validation hub have produced an
R package called Risk Metric
that takes these that I just
talked about and many more
quality Metrics into account to
help you get an objective
assessment of package quality.
And once you've done your
reviews and done your assessments,
and decide in which packages
you want to allow your data
scientists to use,
you can leverage a feature
in positive package manager called
curated repositories.
Allowing you to create
a separate repository just
containing the CRAN or
PyPI packages that you've approved
for use in your team
or organization.
So next,
let's talk about what you
typically think of when you say
security, and that's
vulnerabilities.
And these can occur at
any point in the package
from the source code,
introduced in compiled code or
vulnerabilities that exist in
external libraries that are
used by the package.
And it's important to note
that while these are sometimes malicious,
most often,
these are just due to mistakes
in poorly written code.
But they're still just as
important to to assess and resolve.
So mitigating vulnerabilities is
actually a little bit easier
for public packages,
and that's because the
packages are known published quantities.
You don't generally need
to worry about scanning them
yourself because numerous
others are scanning these
already published packages and
reporting any vulnerabilities on them.
So the best resource for
mitigating those are through
databases of known
vulnerabilities.
In CRANs case, are
relatively few vulnerabilities reported,
partially due to that strong
curation of packages due to the
bouncer of the door.
But Posit has recently started
working with the R consortium
on building out an advisory
database to track known
vulnerabilities in a
standardized format that was
first adopted by the
widely used Python packaging advisory
database that's maintained by
the Python Packaging authority.
Both of these now feed into
the OSV open source vulnerability database
that was, created by Google and
and is the best source
for looking up known
vulnerabilities in both r and
Python packages at this point.
Once you have that, You
can leverage a feature in package
manager called
package blocking.
Where instead of taking a
bottom up curated approach to
approving every package
you want to make available,
you can instead go top down
and allow the majority of packages
available in the
public repositories,
giving your users the most
compatibility with everything
that's out there,
but still blocking the ones
that have known vulnerabilities
and even for blocking packages
that may have, license open
source licenses that you
don't wanna make available inside
your organization.
Now,
separate from the security risk
in the packages themselves,
there are a couple more
malicious risks that prey on
weaknesses in the
infrastructure that is used to
distribute these packages.
We group these into a category
called package confusion,
which in simplest terms is
all about deceiving the user into
installing the wrong package.
So instead of getting the
package they want to use,
they are tricked into installing
a malicious package that they don't.
The two risks we'll talk about
today are type o squatting and
dependency confusion,
which are some of the
more common ones and most high
profile ones that we've
seen in the last year.
So I'm going going to start
and give some examples in terms of
Python packages as due to those
that more permissive nature of PyPI.
These have shown up in
high profile real world exploits in
the past year.
But the same cases can apply
to the r package repositories as well.
So first, let's learn
about type of squatting.
And let's start with you,
the data scientist or developer.
And, we're sitting at
our local machine, and you,
let's say we wanna
start a machine learning project.
And so you want to
grab your TensorFlow package from PyPI.
You use the standard
Python installation utility PyPI and
say PIP install TensorFlow,
which is the command
to install TensorFlow,
equivalent to doing an install dot
packages and r to install a
package from the from prem.
And so PIP goes out to PyPI.
Looks for a package
called TensorFlow. Downloads it,
installs it into
your environment. Perfect.
Everything's fine.
But now let's, start again
back in our clean environment.
We've still got PIPI there,
but this time, when we try to
install TensorFlow,
we accidentally make a typo and had
two n's in the name of the
package. So pip so we have
PIP install TensorFlow with two n's.
PIP goes out and looks for
it on PIPI and can't find a
package by that name and
returns an error. You notice
you mistype the name, fix it,
and try again? All as well.
That's what you expect
to happen in those situations,
and nothing inherently
wrong with that.
But here's where things get scary.
So let's go back to our
our clean environment here.
And let's say that
some evil person
try up up to no good looks
at the most popular public
packages on PyPI. Like
TensorFlow, which, for example,
gets downloaded from PIPI
on average about six hundred
thousand times a day globally.
And so they take that and
they write their own malicious
package and upload it to PyPIwith
a bunch of different similar names,
that are common things that you
might make type by accident if
you were make if you were
trying to install the actual
TensorFlow package,
So now we let's take
our same scenario.
We try to install TensorFlow with
two n's in it and make the
same type it was before,
but instead of getting
an error this time,
PIP goes out and to PyPI
and finds a malicious this
malicious person that
someone put there.
And with the same
name, downloads it,
and we've been exploited now because
we've gotten the wrong packaging here.
So these are tough
to mitigate against.
But there are a few
things that we can do.
And I should point out again
that these are higher risk on
with PyPI than on CRAN
due to the more permissive publishing
nature we talked about.
But one thing working to our
advantages in that case is that
there are many organizations
and companies in the
Python community watching for these
malicious packages now.
So they're identified
relatively quickly once they
are published, usually
within a few days or less.
So the simplest mitigation
we can do is just avoid the
latest packages and updates
from public repositories
and give them time to
be discovered, reported,
and blocked or removed.
And so, you know, latest
isn't always the safest there.
And sometimes it's worth it to
sacrifice a bit of cutting edge
and com compatibility,
for for in the
name of security.
So in package manager,
we can leverage,
what we call repository snapshots
to easily pin our installation
source to a slightly older
versions of the repositories.
We we also get the added
benefit of reproducibility of
our projects by not
always getting updates the packages
that might break
our existing code.
And, you know, it's
not a perfect solution,
but it's one tool that can
be used together with these other
strategies we're talking
about to reduce our risks.
Finally,
I wanna talk about a different
variant that prays particularly on larger teams,
especially those who develop
and share their own internal
packages to
supplement their work,
then we call
dependency confusion.
So let's go back into
our clean environment here where we're
now part of a larger company
that has its own internal packages.
Let's say we're at Posit,
and we have our internal Posit
Tools package that we use along
with some public
packages from PyPI.
We may even be so sophisticated
as to have our own internal
packages and a PyPI like, repository
so that PIP can
install from there.
So we we wanna install POSIT
Tools. We add this extra index
URL flag to our
internal server.
So so that it can find
where our additional packages are. In reality,
this is pro this extra index
URL setting is probably set as
part of our system
configuration,
so we don't have to remember to
type it every time we install something.
But I include this here because
this is exactly what would
actually happen in reality.
So let's say PIP goes out,
looks for a positive tools
package on PyPI, doesn't find
it, realizes it's not there,
So it's probably an
internal package,
and then finds it on searches
the extra index URL, finds it
on our internal repository
and installs it.
I also need pandas, so I do
the same command. But in this time,
it does find it on PyPI
and installs it just as expected.
So everything's perfect until our
mill our malicious actor steps in.
So An evildur is Taza
is targeting positive employees, for example,
and maybe guesses that
we probably have an internal
packaging deposit tools
that's not available on PyPI.
Maybe it you know,
a lot of companies have
internal packages like this for
connecting to
internal resources, databases,
or other internal sources.
And So this malicious actor
creates a their own malicious
package and gives it a name.
They think that our company
might use internally,
like Posit tools. And
they published it on PyPI,
probably with a large version
number, in this case, like,
nine point o. So it looks
newer than anything else.
And now let's we go back to
our user who's trying to, say,
upgrade Posit tools they
have installed. And so they,
say this before, have
their extra index URL and,
and PIP goes out,
and it sees this newer
version of POSIT Tools,
not from our internal
repository, but available now
on PyPI. And it doesn't
know any better,
assumes that's what you
want, and installs it,
and you've been exploited.
So,
you know,
there's lots of variants of
this with not not just directly
installing packages,
but these packages being
dependencies of other packages,
and all of this can happen,
but in a similar way here.
So this,
this one's actually great
because POSit package manager
can completely insulate you from
this case using a unified
local lip repository.
So in that case, we put
our all of our packages,
access all of our
packages through package manager,
we put our internal packages
in front of the public package
repository and present that to
the user as a single repository
taking that decision of
which package to install completely
out of PIP's hands. So now when
we ask PIP to install Posit
Tools, from our
repository here. Again,
it's probably been
preconfigured,
so we don't have to
add the package manager address directly.
But there's only one that that PIP
knows to to pull things from there.
And so pip goes out, asks
package manager now. I
need the positive tools
package, and package manager
knows, hey, I'm always gonna
give you the internal one,
and I'm because I know that the
internal package supersedes the the public one,
and I will never ever serve
you the public package.
And we've been and our
case is solved. Similarly,
I use using the same
same server. I asked for pandas.
Pandas does not in the inter
in my internal package source.
So package manager
says, okay. Here you go.
Here's the public
one from from PyPI,
and still taking advantage of
all the other security measures
that we can also use
the cure curated package
blocking or even repository
snapshots can all be used
in conjunction with these local
and public
repository, con unify.
Everyone's happy.
And we've solved the and we've
solved at least one of many
security risks that we
have to worry about.
But,
in summary, you know, the
reality is we can't deny that
public packages
do present risks.
But really understanding those
risks gives you the knowledge
to manage them.
Today, we've talked about
some of those strategies
and how tools like Posit
Package Manager can help you
reduce some of those risks.
And for those of you interested
in learning more about Posit Package Panager.
I wanna make you aware of
our free hosted service,
Posit Public package Manager,
or p 3 m. We provide a
full mirrors of CRAN, bioconductor, and
PyPI that are free to use,
including historic snapshots that
you can take advantage of.
As well as the added benefit
of our positive built binary CRAN
packages to make things easier and
faster to install in your r environment.
You can find it out, and explore
it today at p three m dot dev,
and definitely reach out to
Posit if you're interested in
learning more about
the advanced risk management
features we talked about today and
how you can bring the power
of Posit package manager
into your own organization.
Thank you so much.
Thanks so much, Joe.
It's great to be able to
dive deeper into package manager today.
And while we're not jumping over
to a live q and a session
here, both Joe and Ryan Johnson
are here hanging out in the
chat to answer any
questions that you have.
So we'll leave this chat open
for the next fifteen minutes or
so. You can type your questions
into YouTube or use the slide
link for anonymous questions.
The short link for
that for Slido is
pos.it/demo-questions, which you can
see on the screen.
We host these monthly end to
end workflow demos on the last
Wednesday of every month, we'd love
to have you join us again.
The last five months,
Ryan Johnson has walked us
through workflows for deploying
visualizations to stakeholders
with Dash and shiny,
shared how to create scheduled
and company branded quarto docs
for redundant reports
and also two ways to ensure
consistent and up to date data
in your work with APIs
and also with pins.
The link to those previous
workflow demos are also in the
YouTube description below.
But thank you again
for joining us today.
Ryan and Joe will be here
in chat for questions.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.